Jim quoi que je fasse je le fais pour te protéger tu
vois je comprends je comprends
ouais ouais
notre rébellion est tout ce qui reste pour
repousser l'Empire
tu penses que tu pourrais peut-être nous aider
quand était la dernière fois que tu as été en
contact avec ton père quoi  est-ce qu'il
semble qu'il est essentiel au
développement d'une super arme
si mon père a construit cette chose, nous devons
le trouver bien combien ai-je besoin,
ils demandent un indicatif d'appel, un
voyou Row one mais nous avons affaire à
ici est  incommensurable
si l'Empire a ce genre de pouvoir
quelle chance avons-
nous nous avons l'espoir que les rébellions sont construites sur l'
espoir
je n'ai aucune idée que nous arrivons
et le code de ce moment les forces attirent
font que 10 hommes se sentent comme cent
prennent la prochaine chance
vous  're rebelles sur vous
vous
le monde se défait Les
drapeaux impériaux pleuvent à travers la galaxie
peut-on vous faire confiance sans vos chaînes,
finissons-en avec nous
avons-nous une mission pour vous
un test d'armes majeur est imminent
nous devons savoir comment  le détruire
est-il vraiment en train de faire ça je veux aider le
bien
je recrute
depuis longtemps à travers la rébellion ils ont détruit
notre côté l'empire maintenant
je ne crains rien tout est comme la force
Wilson
le capitaine dit que tu es un ami je
ne te tuera pas
Merci, il n'y a pas beaucoup de temps chaque jour,
ils deviennent plus forts, il y
a quatre-vingt-dix-sept virgule six pour
cent de chances d'échec,
cela signifie bien que c'est
une chance,
es-tu avec moi
tout le long,
indique ton nom pour l'enregistrement
Jen aussi  falsification de documents impériaux
possession de biens volés voies de fait
graves résistance à l'arrestation par
vous-même à partir de l'âge de 15 ans téméraire
agressif et indiscipliné c'est une
rébellion n'est-ce pas
caution IRA nous avons une mission pour vous un
test d'armes majeur est imminent nous devons
savoir  ce que c'est et comment le détruire
est si clair oui que ferez-vous quand ils
vous attraperont que ferez-vous ils vous
salueront
si vous continuez à vous battre
que deviendrez-
vous
c'est comme le fantasme que vous avez toujours en tant
qu'enfant partout est un  caractère incroyable et
étonnant,
il s'agit de l'humanité de celui-ci qui
rend le tout si réel J'essaie de faire
battre votre cœur et vous êtes en fait
dans cette situation, vous obtenez quelque chose de très
authentique que vous pouvez la plante, vous allez
réellement composer des plans si nous  étaient sur un
écran vert, vous n'auriez tout simplement pas
su que nous étions disponibles frais est si élevé que
nous faisons un film qui
touche juste mon film préféré de tous les temps,
mais si vous le respectez trop,
vous l'avez fait '  ne faites rien de nouveau ou
de différent, prenez un risque, alors
qu'apportez-vous à la table,
tuez le Père Noël là-bas,
je veux dire, c'est vraiment là qu'une équipe de tournage
comme celle-ci entre vraiment dans leurs
propos sur les enfants quand vous aviez quatre ans
a grandi avec des personnages de Star Wars  c'est un
peu comme redevenir cet enfant que
la force soit avec nous
toi